[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is my
wonderful fun interesting insightful
chat with the wonderful fun funny
interesting and insightful Josh Peck who
has a great book called happy people are
annoying a lot of you probably grew up
watching him on Drake and Josh he's also
on How I Met Your Father Oppenheimer
which hasn't come out yet he's also just
an incredible and interesting and
compelling individual and I was so happy
to sit down with him uh it turns out
again you'll you'll see what I mean by
that as we get into the chat but I was
so happy that we got to do this uh
conversation I'm so glad that you guys
are here to tune in uh before we get to
it just a couple just a couple just a
couple tiny things go to petehomes.com
I'm going to be in Royal Oaks Michigan
this weekend and then followed by
Cleveland at hilarities go to
petehomes.com based on how Cleveland is
selling might be the last time I go to
Cleveland so swing by Cleveland for my
farewell Cleveland I guess I don't sell
that great in Cleveland tour
which is sort of a heartbreaker because
uh Cleveland was the Tate that I had
right before the the lockdown I was
going to be in fact I was in Cleveland
when everything got shut down and flew
back so this is really full circle but I
just found out like some of the shows
are like 10 sold which is maybe because
it's Father's day but I'm a father and
I'll I'll [__] be there come on
Cleveland anyway go to pdoms.com for
tickets to every city that I'm going to
be in and there are a bunch of them I
also only have one pizza pick up top for
you and you guys you got you guys know
it's magic mind you know I and I [__]
I I self-believed I [__] love magic
mine magic mind is a productivity drink
it is new atropics which is like
vitamins for your brain uh it's uh
adaptogens which help your body cope
naturally with stress and it's just a
Teensy bit of caffeine and a Teensy bit
of Honey which makes you happy and I
love it it gives you like five hours
hours of dialed in Focus they jokingly
call it creatorade like we have Gatorade
for athletes now we have Creator Aid it
just puts you in that flow State there's
no product that has changed my creative
process more than magic mind and there's
no product that I've given away to my
creative friends to my writer friends to
my painter friends photographer friends
to my actor friends anybody I know that
uses their Noggin and is doing something
creative magic mind is here to elevate
your mood dial you in and get you
dropped into that flow State it's
designed to be taken with your coffee
that's what the adaptogens are for they
round the edges of your caffeine intake
that you're already taking so you take
it as a as a as a as a chaser with your
caffeine or if you're like me I just
took one because I was a little groggy
this afternoon just take it by itself
either way so many of my friends there's
Leela in the background have been turned
on to Magic mine and absolutely love it
and I absolutely love it I was passing
on my Instagram I posted that somebody
was um fishing pretending to be my
assistant or something there's Val
taking Leela out of the frame and uh I
love that somebody in the comments said
you can tell it's not Pete because he
didn't talk about magic mind well fair
play to you I can't shut up about magic
mind
um you should try it it's a great way to
support your creative process and
support the show go to magicmine.com
weird and use my discount code to check
out weird for a limited 20 off your
first order I absolutely love it it's a
huge game changer so try it get into it
I'm sure I offer it to Josh here on the
show so all right hope to see you on my
farewell Cleveland tour
or in Royal Oaks Michigan or anywhere go
to petehomes.com and in the meantime
enjoy this chat with the wonderful Josh
Peck get into it this is a nightmare
Josh
I just said nice to meet you
and he's like we've we've met and I was
like where and he said here he came here
to do I was on his
solve it up and uh and I'm like where
where did we record it thinking maybe we
went to a coffee shop we couldn't have
been here and he said in this room with
the sauna and then tell tell them what
happened
um and then 45 minutes in peace
happy 45. he goes it had to be an hour
we're gonna have to cut this soon
and I was like uh yeah yeah for sure
I okay I look you're an upbeat and
delightful person do you ever run out
of being delightful like you know just
kind of gas in general you could you
can't run your delightful engines and
maybe you're just kind of tired of
talking I guess yes all the time meaning
yes okay thank you because if I said
that
because I'm a very non-confrontational
person I'd rather eat the 15 do the hour
and then be like but I must have been
worried that we were flowing or
something I was like this feels like a
two hour and people do do that to me a
lot which is not you but because I have
a a long form podcast most people are
like well he'll probably go two hours
yeah on my podcast and if I'm rested and
in a good place and don't have a lot to
do I will but like I must have been
so thin at that time spread thin you
were I must have been but I am
humiliated
you know human I say this all the time
but humiliate same uh prefix same root
word as humble so it's good to be
humiliated I look I don't want anyone to
be humiliated yes but if you want to
alchemize your own humiliations and go
like this is good I'm being humbled
because every you know what I mean like
it's good to be humble right is it that
we are humbled but then we life humbles
us and but then we're humiliated we
humiliated
plus mind humbling plus story is
humiliation
that should have never happened to me
yes but humbling is like this is I was
on uh touring with um one of my
operators Paris to Shay and normally you
know I got the pre-check and I'm trying
to get in like all the fast lines all
the all the TSA things that I could to
be a fancy boy at the airport yes and we
were just in the longest line there was
nowhere there was no way around it this
airport was [__] every way yes and she
was just like this is good Pete humbling
and I was like she's right she's right
so this story is worse
I am
despite all my best efforts not always
as shiny and nice as and as
um generous or spacious as I want to be
you know what I mean I get it I I
certainly get it because you're I think
your first instinct is right is in the
Rogan era of podcasts it's possible
especially with comedians that someone
could say this is working let's keep it
go yeah let's go and go which would be
an impossibility in almost every other
entertainment Forum yes right it's a set
amount of time there's no way no world
in which we're going three hours it's
insane right right right and you didn't
sign up for that and you were I I must
you said though it was crashing press
time and that time must have been yes I
that's how I think I got you and not to
project but I'm like I'm sure you were
like you saw okay kids verified on
Instagram got some followers right there
to me right now this is a nightmare It's
gotta be this is a true and living here
for me just because of how real it is
and that doesn't make me bad or the
system bad but it doesn't make either of
us good Miami or the meaning that is
part of it you get a cold call some guy
you see they have a ton of Instagram
followers you're like maybe it'll move
the needle on the show I get it because
you care about it and you want people to
see it yeah around the same time in my
life I'm still embarrassed and
humiliated humbled I'm so humbled you're
humble good humble but around the same
time I met a guy on that porch that we
just walked past for the New York Times
I've told this story before but I really
would like to see what it makes you
think of I was on empty and I just
didn't have it wasn't that I didn't ever
like press training or something but I
didn't have what I have now which is
like take the New York Times seriously
yes because everyone reads the New York
Times
right but apparently everyone does
because whenever I do the New York Times
everyone would reach out you know what I
mean for some reason I just didn't take
it seriously and this guy met me on the
porch and I was so tired I was beyond
tired and I know you've been that kind
of tired I mean zero yeah and this guy
was there and I was like
like that's just how I felt I'm not
proud I'm not too proud to admit it
though I didn't want to do an interview
I turned it on as best as I could and it
wasn't a smear piece but there were like
a lot of like the line that really hurt
my feelings was like I asked him if he
wanted to get a coffee which I thought
was like nice like hey let's go make
this more more good let's caffeinate
ourselves yeah she can get energetic
about hating me yes yes and he said
looking at me in the eye for the first
time
that's rough yeah yes that's right that
is someone who prides himself I want to
think of myself as generous as
gregarious as connected as present and
this guy's like this guy was a dick I
hated it he also got the color of my car
wrong which I I found just unacceptable
I didn't like it he said I drove a white
SUV what's that the failing New York
Times yeah exactly you can get the color
right now didn't like it I didn't like
it and we've since moved but he made it
very clear where I lived and I was like
what is this guy doing weird yeah does
anything like that happen you tell me
what do you got you have to you I am
safe to be careful of false humility
which I think is important too right
yeah because I've waited false humility
is important or being careful of it
being careful of it in those instances
or just knowing what I'm capable of in
that moment like do I have the capacity
to be my normal human self yeah I
remember someone once asked me to do
their podcast over over Instagram much
as you agreed to mine then there was a
bunch of college kids and I'm like you
know what
minds of tomorrow let me give them a
little something yeah yes you're in that
mood and I do it and I get on and I was
on a kid show for many years called
Drake and Josh which I'm very proud of
because it's made a lot of people happy
which I don't want to talk about it
nauseam
yes I understand and it's and it starts
with Drake and Josh and I'm like give
him a couple
bye
give thank you because I've been feeling
like the jerk that checked your
Instagram follow and said yeah so you're
doing the same thing you're like okay
I'm gonna but even even different you're
like I'm gonna stoop down yes and help
these poor sons of [__] yes yes I
understand so you go I'll give them a
couple okay yeah yeah we're not really
friends or we are whatever it is I'm not
even asking I'm just saying like you
give them a couple and then you go on
and I went on and I and then 15 minutes
in now I'm starting to shoehorn my other
working yeah because I'm like I can't do
I can't do a deep dive into episode 216.
I need to move on and so do you
okay
it becomes an intervention for them yeah
their addiction to the show from the
star of the show it's like guys I
thought I was your guest I'm actually
your life raft yeah stop it I'm now
redirecting their own podcast to them
and you're answering the question you
wish they had asked by the way and in 30
minutes I go we're done yeah and I love
the way I said sorry guys I'm gonna have
to pull up Pete Holmes here
as it says
here's the fun thing about life you can
play almost anything from both angles
you know as a comedian
our job is to stick our heels into one
usually and have fun just defending one
because there's two sides to everything
the other side of both of these stories
is is there anything more beautiful than
a tired person just being like look I'm
having a good time but we have to wrap
this up pretty soon like it's not it's
not you're not Santa Claus in that
moment yes but aren't you also a person
this is something Val my wife helps me
do with my family my family will ask me
for for something I don't want to give
it and then like let's say it's a visit
and I I feel like I just saw them or
they were just here or something like
that but they're like come again and I'm
like I really don't want to do that but
then I get guilted in my own mind I'm
like you should and Val will be like
Pete you are also a person that deserves
love isn't it loving to yourself yeah to
say you know what I feel like we were
just there we didn't enjoy that but
let's let's not do another one that's a
joke but it's not really a joke let's
not do another one so soon like she
helped me realize you're in play as well
you think because you're looking out for
yourself interest that your interests
aren't as valuable as other people's
interests does that make sense where's
so where where does people pleasing stem
from in us do you think
I think well because in doing my
research of you I feel like you and I
are very similar and we correct me if
I'm wrong but I feel like we were hammy
kids I was also a soft boy yeah and I
realized very quickly
not when I say manipulate I mean I was a
kid looking for any control over Reality
by control I don't mean a Machiavellian
manipulation of of reality and like I
don't know split the prophets it's not
like that no desire to feel safe and I
wanted to feel safe yes I wanted to feel
safe and I and one of the things that
makes me feel the safest is confirmation
that I've been heard so when someone
laughs you have a visceral physical
involuntary confirmation that they not
only heard you which is uh-huh but they
understood you you changed them it's
like you made them sneeze and there's no
child laugh there's there's a pandering
laugh that everyone gets child or adult
yeah and there's a genuine laugh that
child and adult can get yeah so when
you're a kid and an adult gives you the
same laugh that they would give their
peer you go I'm a peer you did it I'm a
peer you just gave me the chills that's
exactly what it was yes you were like I
think I can and when I again when I say
game I mean figure out a way to work
this system just to make me feel
psychologically sound yeah and if I
could make my teachers laugh you know
the kids are I still feel this way even
I remember being in junior high and I
was like farts are pretty big
you know the girls like like a little
bit more like this or like gross out
stuff or or rhyming or singing a silly
song I did an alpha impression and this
brings me back to like feeling similar
to you I just had that like I was
looking for it yes outside of the house
and that that's not even putting down my
family I'm just saying like I was
getting more payback from strangers and
I love it and I still love it is that do
you relate tell me that really something
you just said I remember when I was a
kid and I had like a wonderful you know
gypsy-esque Mom like not Gypsy Rose but
like Gypsy the musical right like we're
gonna get it baby yeah you know and she
was not uh uh she was what was required
of a stage mother at that time like she
saw talent and and ability in me and she
poured jet fuel on it yeah so it wasn't
like get out there but it was like if
you got it I've heard you first of all
let me do this for you you were raised
by your mother you're the product of one
night stand I'm not being crass right it
was like a one night stand yeah nine
months later crazy little Joshy pack and
it's you and your mom I also heard you
beautifully say that you were like a
startup it's like other other families
are like corporations and there's upper
management and there's seniority it was
brilliant I loved what you said I'm just
trying to spare you from having to say
the same time no but you were the man in
your mom's life and you were a
partnership yeah and it's and and you
said that by the way you said I was the
man of my mother you're right it feels
correct yes because I understand you
know paging Dr Freud there's a blurring
there that can be
unfair on maybe you question mark yeah I
don't know with a single mom and an only
child especially in the realities of
like 80s
self-made woman in very much a man's
world deep Financial insecurity like
there was no especially because there
was no sparing me from the realities of
like what our life was gonna have to be
yes and I say in in my book I'm like for
all of us the veil of adolescence Falls
at a certain time in our life and we
realize that life is unfair and like the
realities kind of come in it just
depends at what age yes and I guess it's
called the wound yeah yeah it's that's
why they confirm Catholic children I
think it's seven because that's the
first one I'm not saying that's the big
one right but that's usually when the
veil starts to crack a little bit and
you go like oh no yeah that bird wasn't
sleeping you know like you're right but
it's dead and my food is dead and Nana's
dead like all that stuff starts coming
through yeah and I I think that was all
so for me I felt that with my mom and I
just had to elevate I had to be upgraded
to this role of co-pilot like a like a
startup like sometimes she was the CEO
and I was the assistant and sometimes
vice versa yeah yeah yeah but I think
about how and my mom was older right she
had me at 43 so now I'm 36 she's 79. wow
and growing up I had you know I had good
pitch in school I was like um I could
sing and I was eight years old and there
was the talent show
and I remember like you thinking when I
would see kids either do just a dance
yeah they would dance to a pop song and
or just listen to the delightful fire of
your judgment I was just a dance I'm
like you're in the back smoking it a
candy cigarette being like Oh yeah Hit
Me Baby One More Time the radio you're
like not having a good day
yes and you just and we can hear your
one foot tapping because you're wearing
a tap shoe you're about to go on my
capezios and then someone gives you a
bowler hat and you're like let's show
them how it's done yeah I I'm so with
you it was unacceptable it was
unacceptable and the one level why were
they liking it why were they liking it
why were they eating it no one should
have liked this yeah and then one step
up was you did a song from Aladdin yeah
or Beauty and the Beast I'm like too
topical
yeah I can show you the world heard it
yeah been there been there hated it the
first time yeah oh you're doing a Mickey
classic great and soon the heavy lifting
so songwriting it's doing the heavy lift
I'm with my mother who was born at the
end of World War II who's like you're
gonna go up there and either sing New
York New York or make someone happy the
Jimmy Durante version and I'm like
you're gonna bring it down load me in
mom and I would [__] bring down the
house and think that's how it's done oh
yeah so a mom who could have been a
comedian what had performer chops
business and comedy I know that sounds
sort of absurd but there's like a
there's like a go get it yeah about it
there's like a close and kill yeah those
things are close but she didn't have the
luxury to like go off and pursue it but
now she has this little dazzling boy
this Razzle Dazzle yes and she's like
you you said it yourself she was like
the good version of a stage Mom that she
was like I think I see genuine interest
and ability and I'm just gonna tell them
you don't have to sing from Aladdin yeah
you can sing New York New York
the sheet music today we're gonna I'm
gonna really Vamp here like you know
yeah hold during the bridge
[Music]
you throw a cane dear teacher they're
not ready
I did have a game yeah I I'm trying to
remember what I sang I sang first of all
I did like WC Fields I had a little
bamboo can I go get out of here kid
you're bothering me I don't even know
what I'm doing yeah I'm playing
alcoholic basically painted Ken I'm
hungover but I would sing those Classics
too but I didn't have the the Broadway
chops but you did I did did you remember
what it felt like to hit that note in
New York New York or whatever or if you
say the other one yeah it was it
electric and exciting or it was a the
most electric moment I think of my life
which set me on this path was being like
eight years old at a Jewish holiday
dinner and me just piping up in the
middle of the dinner and retelling a
joke I'd heard my mom say four years no
about I say oh no because I just love it
yeah so much it's like I just realized
the mashed potatoes are Lobster mashed
potatoes you're like really well this
just turned into a 30 side
but it's we're not paying we're not
paying no it's a good surprise this is
gorgeous nobody wants the 30 side okay
so you wrote do you remember the joke
yeah it was it's a classic borsche spell
joke you want me to do it yeah I'd love
to hear it okay so it takes something I
wanted you to sing in New York New York
only because it made you know the vagus
nerve is activated when you sing so me
just going
I remember there was oh okay now I I it
it all comes flooding back so my mom
would tell this joke and around her
seven six seven-year-old kid which was
woman wants to get a breast enlargement
she goes she's not dead already done
woman wants to get her breast
enlargement oh yeah or as I say making
the canteen a little bit bigger am I
right mom's got that good two percent
this guy knows what I'm talking about
and this is early 90s like breast
enlargement surgery is cutting out like
your mom making her way in the business
World Murphy Brown was like science
fiction
she goes when wants to get her breast
enlarge when she goes to Dr Goldstein
and Dr the little kind of Jewish flavor
and I love it people are enjoying it
we're in Boca
she says Dr Goldstein says I have a
different approach don't worry you don't
have to go under the knife you just have
to go like this
and if you get bored just go Mary had a
little lamb and come back to me in a
month so a month later she's looking
great she's got like she's her bust has
grown and she's walking around kid knows
the word bust but like three levels of
polite down not breasts yeah not boobies
her bust is looking dare I say robust a
woman with a long Ash cigarette like she
needs to dab it goes and then it falls
off yeah just a Benson and hedges
110.
she's got a Benson burn to the filter
let me tell you the ash falls off
because she laughs just at that moment I
got him on the hook this is you telling
your other six-year-old friend yes the
story of the joke later oh man I'm like
I hear the ash fall I'm like I would
tell you guys but you wouldn't
understand of course they wouldn't you
needed to talk to other like 60 year old
Jewish women oh yeah who had no
boundaries that's right right because
the fathers of my friends who are like
in their 30s would treat me normally
which would be like huh yeah and I'd be
like you don't get it either you don't
get it you're disrespecting it can I
also say we're gonna get back to that
joke don't you worry oh I believe the
men are threatened I think they are I
think so women there's something go look
not all women some women have all the
different levels I'm all about it but
I'm just saying traditionally especially
it feels like in the 80s yes men would
see a little [__] like us wooin and
kahooting and winning over them comes
and they [__] hated us
right yes am I right and then the women
they were these bad they're bosoms
that's the other polite one they're they
were just soft welcoming bosoms that
were like look at little Josh's shine
and they gave us the Applause the men
gave us that withholding you won't win
me over until you're on Nickelodeon you
know that drove you or anything or even
just like or or you
um Ascend the levels of masculinity like
unless you're hitting home runs I don't
give a [__] that's right I felt the same
way I still feel that way I was gonna do
a man's rite of passage thing just
because I'm stupid but and I said to
them I was like let me ask you this when
it comes to like defeats of strength
because I'm assuming there's some Feats
of Strength yeah is it like balance and
lifting and [__] because why is it
always the stuff that you [__] can do
you know what I mean why is it always
the scary stuff that you [__] just so
happen to be naturally talented at
that's right off I can't do a push-up
but I performed for 7 000 people eat it
you know what I mean I'm still mad about
it yeah like I don't force you to come
into my mail initiation and write a
tight ten right because I'm not a
[__] [__] but they're but culture
was going like you better learn how to
hit a home run I can't hit a home run
yeah but I'm cracking up the bench you
piece of [__] yeah why don't you try the
balance beam you [__] yeah exactly
yeah men don't do the balance beams yeah
that's right right that's all right
pirouette I don't know I wish I could do
a flip but I'll try yes yes I can't
climb the Rope totally but I can do a
great thing about rope burn I gotta type
five on rope burn but we're warped too
because when my wife does a beautiful
job of reminding me of this that I I
Pander to kids in some respect like I
talk to kids in a way I try I hate I
never want to be that adult that talks
down to them but sometimes I talk to
them in an appropriate way that reflects
their age and where they are that's
right and so adults which means you go
hey kid this girl goes in for a boob job
I would tell them talk to them
differently I I just talked to them in
an appropriate Way for their age but me
at that age I would think oh you don't
[__] know that I'm the man of my
house and you're talking to me at an
appropriate age range for what you're
seeing but anyway I've brought that with
me like my wife will tell me now at 36
like that guy's not disrespecting you
yeah but I I hold that with me still I
do too and that's where comedy came in
it was like oh you think you're you're
stupid now to me right you're stupid oh
oh this guy's
me in the corduroy blazer you know what
I mean and you want to disarm them and
win and I had a little I don't know if
it's edible or what but there was
something I was like I'll win all the
ladies and all the men are gonna go that
guy was a real gem like that was in me I
couldn't stand being condescended to or
something and I for me it was I don't
know if I'm getting the feeling was the
same it's because my mother made me feel
like I was the most magical boy in the
world and I feel like she saw me and I
felt like she was right and I'm really
glad I learned the humility and I
learned what I wasn't good at later but
it sounds like you benefited from that
which takes you to this joke you're like
I can tell this joke because your mom
was the wind under your wings right yeah
I remember I I remember when I got my
first uh I was on Amanda Bynes had a
sketch comedy show The Amanda Show yes
and it was the thing that brought me out
tele and I was 13 years old I'll never
forget this and I'm shaking it up real
Razzle Dazzle I am putting I'm in Bow
Tie Andrew
this is I am budding so much English on
this shot
that the cue ball has come back I've
done a 360. put so much English
is incredible yes you're going You're
chewing the scenery there's so many
great terms for it but you already did
the best one you didn't know not to ham
it up I was like this is good this is
what they want and I'll never forget the
director yells cut and looks me goes
Josh and he goes
it's like you're really milking it right
so this guy's going for laughs now yeah
I'm like first of all what are we
talking what is this yeah like you're uh
pulling me up yeah you can just talk to
me you tell me the slide you [__] you're
what pops up from the future and goes
this man isn't disrespecting you not yet
not yet
not yet right now yes right now he is
but I didn't I was like and I literally
thought and what's the problem yeah
exactly I'm I heard you say you loved
Sandler I like Billy Madison yeah like a
lot of our favorite actors I I'm just
gonna assume growing up were over actors
meaning they weren't going for like a
Sean Penn type close-up you know what I
mean they were doing they were going for
almost like
yeah it was it was huge Gleason oh
and Jim Carrey still destroys me these
guys that can sneak in and sell you a
glass of milk because they know deep
down you do want a glass of milk I feel
the same way when I can get a crowd
laughing at diarrhea or something and
I'm like I knew you dumb [__] wanted to
you just won't let yourself yes you
won't let yourself because you think you
subscribe to the New Yorker [__] you
subscribe to Bon Appetit I should have
said a dumb magazine I said another high
class but it happens it's pretty good
okay it was fine it was fun to say US
Weekly use your eyes weekly
[__] and you know it you're a
steak at Applebee's that's JoJo said to
me this week yeah I was taking
Applebee's oh keep going please keep
going you know you put a lot of Judge so
yeah so and but this idea that milking
it is a bad thing yeah I it was a
breakthrough moment I remember when I I
I talk about this and I'm I'm jumping
all over but like at 26 or 27 I like hit
this Plateau work-wise right just felt
like I had developed these bad habits
yeah and I could just tell like I could
be good sometimes but it wasn't
consistent and I'd been doing it too
long to not be consistent and I was
tired of this feeling how did you notice
this
reviews no really was that or watching
yourself too both both yeah so yeah I
was just like I could be really good or
really bad and I just was like this
isn't working can I ask I know you're in
the middle of something I don't want to
split it too many ways but like was that
did you feel like you were like based on
mood like I was in a good mood that day
and I really turned it on but I was in a
bad mood and I couldn't find it or was
it just the material or what what it
made it inconsistent it was two things
if if the the part was in my wheelhouse
then I could find enough connection to
myself where I could root it in
something real because it was close to
me yeah but like the whole idea with
acting right it's like well you have to
be able to hopefully play somewhat a
variety of character maybe you won't be
Daniel Day-Lewis and disappear right
right but like you might need to be able
to play an accountant you imagine Daniel
Cott
age
you're milking it yeah I drink your
milkshake how much is I drink your
milkshake you don't know that was a bit
much what do you mean by that I my
friend was on
my friend was on was worked on There
Will Be Blood and said I don't think I'm
speaking out of school here that in the
middle of takes because he's so in it
but he also has a trailer yeah and
they're putting makeup on it right he
would just say instead of saying like
I'm gonna go back to my trailer you just
go ah I'm I'm gonna go away now that was
how he would say it
yes well I'm gonna go away now yeah and
I will return yeah and then he goes into
an air-conditioned box it is 1898
clothes and just sits there
I also know a fun ddl and we will get
back to every single one of your stories
I just thought it was very interesting
that on Gangs of New York which only
exists in my uh opinion as a character
study that led to There Will Be Blood
yes right yeah that whole movie it was
like when Daniel Day Lewis was on you're
like yeah and then when he wasn't you're
like I don't really care about trolley
theft is this
good yeah it did I know it took 35 years
and 90 million dollars but is it good
yeah but anyway then he was playing
build a butcher
and apparently in between takes to stay
in that evil like ramped up amped up
violent Zone he would listen to Eminem
yeah how funny is that he is it's 1898
knees week arms are heavy vomit on this
sweater already
like that is hilarious while I heard cut
he would blast Eminem while butchering
me yes you heard this I've heard this
listen Eminem while butchering meat
outside of his trailer
or his place that he goes oh yeah I'll
be outside of my place and I go with
Marshall Mathers yeah who won't be born
for 200 years yes
that's way too late but that is
incredible by the way I've heard a lot
of people tease the method thing it's
just as good he's just as close as you
can be you know what I mean I just want
to go on the record and say I know the
other side you can't be perfectly in
character because they are putting
makeup on your face and I know you'd be
like what are these cameras but he's
just doing the best he can and I respect
it I respect it and here's the one thing
like you certainly hear stories of
certain people in quotes giving in my
opinion method a bad name because
it's their process for acting and then
it bleeds into their and as you know as
if you are a producer really if you're
the director or an actor on a set you
set the tone and if you're having a bad
day it means there's a lot of people
that are working on that set that are
that are gonna have a bad day because
you're having a [__] yeah yeah so there
is a little bit you have to be a
politician to a certain extent and like
be a leader and set the tone which is
important yes and I think there's people
who let that method let let whatever
their processes bleed into not being
that leader it's true they could use a
little bit more people please eh a
little bit but you never hear that about
ddl yeah yeah you you've never seen it
in a way it never gets in the way and
people almost like respect it because
they're like wow he's working his ass
off at this thing and it doesn't get in
the way of me maybe we're not talking
about the game last night right right
who cares this is special it's okay I I
briefly talked to Paul Thomas Anderson
one and he said I think Joaquin Phoenix
was doing something similar on the on
the master and I've told the story
before but he said he'd just have
Joaquin go around in character and then
follow him and just film him and I was
like it's a dream yeah if a character is
always in character that means you can
film him at any moment as long as he's
not eating them both Skittles it's
usable yeah I like the lime yeah the
green one is my favorite have you seen
the uh the famous outtake from the
master with Philip Seymour Hoffman oh
the fart no with the menthol cigarettes
yes yes minty flavor minty and they
can't get it out they can't they can't
it's so and enjoy and you see Joaquin go
no no just do it so good yes and I like
that even then they're like aware like
no we're acting but this is good that's
[__] a right it's it's using both
it's like when you're playing the guitar
in a certain Rhythm but then you're
singing in a different not not you not
Rhythm but like you're playing a certain
Melody and you're singing a different
Melody on top of it I know that's just
called music but that's what an actor is
doing too like you can be staying in the
character that's your guitar yeah you
can also be observing your behavior and
watching the movie a little bit and
that's your singing does that make sense
yeah I feel that way I don't know how
you are how are you but you uh a lot of
the things you've done you're also
producing and so you have that extra hat
but are how are you watching yourself
I had to get good at it watching it on
on crashing because right it was
horrible season one and then season two
you're just like it's almost uh have you
heard the term depersonalization yes
it's a symptom of a lot of uh psychic
um psychiatric disorders actually like
it's a bad thing they should suffer from
depersonalization but you can also have
little bits of it and I started feeling
removed from that person to the extent
that you could be like
like I stopped going like oh I look fat
or something that's huge yeah it took
three seasons but by the third season I
was like this guy is fat I'm just
kidding but like I just was like that's
what he looks like right you know what I
mean and that was actually a beautiful
There's Something Beautiful about that
just going like that's me instead of
always seeing the mental image of what
you think you look like you really just
saw your real self yeah if that makes
sense and you got to you got an
opportunity when I say forgive it that
sounds like it's wrong I just mean
accept it you get to accept it yeah how
are you with it I'm I I can't watch
anything that I I never watched dailies
and I can't watch anything until about a
year after it's come out because I feel
like if you're looking at a photo of
yourself from a year or so ago and
you're like I look great or I just I
look fine yeah but you know the day
after you took that photo you were like
ugly [__] yeah right yeah yeah and you
think a year later I was so hard on
myself I think this all the time for one
I have no idea what a peace ass I was
when I was 22.
all of us I thought I was a little booby
jiggling like Weirdo And I was like that
was actually As Good As It Gets
I think I think Judd Apatow is a bit
about that where it's like you you look
at an old picture of yourself and you
can't believe how good you look yes you
know when the picture was taken you were
like I'm having a bad day you know yeah
but you you weren't and I'm that and
you're not right now you know like
that's sort of the lesson right you in
10 years will go like wow there was a
light in my eyes or whatever it was so
much better yeah yeah but the only thing
I do like I'm working on this thing now
and I had to do this kind of bit this
stunt where I fall into a table because
things never change for old Joshy you
want another one
former fatty falls down yes
yes Make Them Fall like he used to yeah
you want another one that had a boss
uh dude I've had to unlearn that but I I
was doing this stun and I'm good we have
to talk about food yes I just because
I'm an overeader and I just want I want
help I want to just talk about it oh I'm
here for you but I like that so that's I
want to join you like three or four
times and like I've done certain things
now which is crazy like I played a U.S
Marshal in this in the Turner and Hooch
reboot yes for like 10 months and I know
that I'm not naturally athletic or
certain things so instead of having a
director
which is funny because I would cast you
white polo white shorts you're in Dead
Poet Society you're one of the
non-thoughtful kids the kind of thing
anyone's ever said right
I've been trying to be non-thoughtful
forever you look like the non-ethan
Hawke thanks you look like you look like
the one that might be like poetries for
for girls or something and then kicks a
rugby ball I don't even know if you I
was intermittent fasting really well for
a couple months and someone on Twitter
said I looked sick and I was like [__]
yeah I do like if sick is the goal
you're sick like you're like literally
beast on you're like you're swole you're
like thanks bro
compliments her bodies are also diseases
you're rich
yeah I'm completing out this is bad I've
ripped but I know when I watch you like
I've had directors try to say in like
the most
um you know just speak in in these broad
terms to try to make me understand
what's wrong with me running yes or me
like throwing a punch or me going
through the table so now I go I'm dead
just show me yeah just show I gotta see
and and then I'll watch I'll go Oh you
mean keep my arm down yeah but like they
felt the news that technical [__] I'm
like I can if it's not about performance
and more about the technical I can watch
it just showing just showing voice over
I go just just tell me how you want me
to say it I don't care yeah I'm not I'm
not disrespected can I put this to you
because people like us that grew up uh
soft boys and I'm not even putting a
judgment on it it's just like I was an
outlier I was I was in a small class and
I was the heaviest so that made me an
outlier I remember even getting to
college and talk about body movement I
was walking towards the car I was only
friends with girls like my whole life
I've always just liked girls that's I
have more guy friends now but anyway in
college it was all girls I'm walking
back to the car and they're in the car
and I can see they're laughing
and it's it's Josh it's not a good one
like I can just tell these are my dear
friends yes I'm still friends with one
of them the other one's dead to me I'm
just kidding I'm walking up to the car
and they're laughing and I got in the
car and I just knew that they were
laughing at my natural walk right and
they were what were you laughing and so
one of them went we were watching you
walk and I just started going
and I was like
oh yeah that's what that if I was uh
playing Bill the Butcher I'd listen to
audio I've done a butcher a cow and I'd
be ready I'd be camera ready man yes
like with the rage would be real in my
eyes do you relate to that like people
like us we get into the fla I love
physical comedy I love playing around
but isn't it strange that that stuff
comes from guys like you and me that do
look a little weird weird we don't look
tight when we run no we're not Tom
Cruise no we're not you know so does
that what does that bring up for you 100
I I've never understood that too now
I've married into a family of athletes
and I just see movement it's incredible
I don't know why there isn't already the
movie of you marrying into a family of
athletes my father-in-law played in the
NFL for 10 years shy maybe more uh dude
and you show up spinning bow tie from
Junior right
I'm literally like throw it to me
it's so bad fantastic like I wanted to
dance your face I'm not gonna throw it
in your face I wanted to throw it and
just have it at your face which you and
I would both do for the laugh you're
like it's technically a stunt just do it
just keep crawling yeah it's fine he is
in the NFL yeah he was in the NFL and
there's these wiry muscle-bound people
passing you Lobster mashed potatoes and
you're like this is a 30 side and
they're like sorry what nothing
oh my my brother-in-law is six eight he
played he was qb1 at Fresno State I
can't I can't do they love you yeah yeah
they love the hell out of me why not
because I'm a different flavor that's
what I mean I'm not a threat if you
showed up and you're just Chris
Hemsworth is that his name yes who needs
another Hemsworth we already got a
hemsworths
that Scrappy
hamboy yeah yeah give his hand I say it
as a ham boy no uh I'm the scrappy hand
boy like I was like
him I'm the scrappy hamboy I am I send
it to my wife I'm like who would have
thought like my wife's last name her
maiden name's O'Brien I'm like who would
have thought that some hot-blooded actor
Jew would have been the perfect one for
you
like in this family it's so perfect
let me wet the Reed on my clarinet give
me a moment to sum it up
yes just another moment dear she's over
there just with a brisket she's carving
a brisket it's so good wait brisket was
kind of Jewish I meant doing something
Macho I couldn't even think of an
example yeah of pork loin thank you
thank you very much yes I get I grew up
Lithuanian not Jewish but I I feel such
kinship we had so many close Jewish
Family Friends yes and I was like those
were the only ones that like understood
Sarah let's not get too into it I'd love
to say on the track we're on but like I
just felt such a warmth and a connection
to those types of families they
understood the love and the conflict in
the in the ways that it was happening in
my house yeah any hoosil woozle where
were we you married well I'll give you a
I'll button up two things we were just
talking about with this guy's a podcast
I love it nobody's ever buttoned up this
is the most unbuttoned podcast of all
time this podcast
[Laughter]
well I like the physicality part that
too was like there were two revelatory
things that happened when I went back to
class at like 27 or 28 and and it was
the first my first day back and like I'm
pretty successful at this point right
like I've at least made a living being
an actor yeah and I guess what's great
about your career too I know we've kind
of teased that I checked your Instagram
followers but that does open certain
doors opportunities and then also it
gives you a number because you have like
three point blah blah blah millions of
subscribers my dad could understand that
right you know what I mean it's it's
like a way of going like here's his
score and you go like that's a big score
it's like the IMDb star meter exactly
yeah so yeah so people can understand
it's a nice thing no it's a good thing
and I I remember going back and I'm
doing my first scene in front of my
teachers so my teacher to this day and
she goes she stops the scene and goes
Josh who am I and she starts walking
around like this
with a hump in her back closed off she's
like I'm you I'm like well you didn't
have to say that like babe I know how
Comedy Works one of these directors that
are like hey [__]
[Music]
the director yeah this is what I needed
you needed this my acting teacher was a
little because I had spent so like I had
been this weight in this shape for 10
years but it was so indoctrinated in me
to close myself off to make myself
smaller because I was so into guard
yourself which is what the the weight
was and that and I thought I was still
caring she's like you can't be strong
and and like what I want to see out of a
man because you're so you're making
yourself so small and weak she's like
now we're gonna have to do more work but
she's like why don't you pull your
shoulders back yeah and put your chest
out yeah and see just that what it does
for you right and that was massive and
the other part with the comedy stuff was
and she had said this because I remember
going like I'll take your drama help I
got the comedy stuff cornered like don't
need your help darling yeah yeah like
back it up lady it's my bread and butter
yeah yeah and she goes no
she was like no no she she goes you have
and she's in her 70s too right she's
like I know your mother like I I feel
like I know your mother and I know what
she showed you growing up and you
watched all that Billy Madison Happy
Gilmore [__] you also watched The
Honeymooners and just like and you know
Three Stooges like borsche belt big loud
schmalty humor she's like but we're in a
different era we're in the office yeah
type comedy that's so nuanced and subtle
she's like
um it's almost like you're the way you
approach comedy is almost out of fashion
like it's not so she's like it's not bad
I love that [__] too and it probably can
work in certain scenarios but it would
behoove you to like hone this kind of
Comedy yeah yeah you're wearing a
double-breasted zoot suit to a nice
tuxedo party like this was cool in 1992
I love this this is Grace by the way it
was those friends that have the the the
gumption I'll say to tell you you have
blueberry in your teeth instead of those
that's right phony ass [__]
that just laugh at you the whole lunch
and you don't even know why that's just
another dude she was saving you she was
saving me and that is the sign to me of
a great teacher right because you don't
have to be a musician to know that it
should go
right like you're everyone's ear goes
that's weird yeah yeah but only a good
teacher can be like let me show you how
to fix it yeah and and not spare your
feelings right because she could have
been nice and been like I like what
you're doing it's really interesting I
I'm that way too like we wanna
told this before but John saruf who's
this great actor out of uh Salem
Massachusetts he he just directed me one
day and he kept noticing that I was
crossing my arms and and he called it my
fear hole he was like you're covering
your fear hole Yeah and and I was like
like I felt so exposed but I did feel
like I later wrote a stand a bit about
it I was like you protect your stomach
because that's a kill stroke for a lion
and your neck is a kill stroke as well
so you protect your neck put your
shoulders up and you you hunch over this
is literally what you do if you're on a
bus that's about to crash right and
that's what we were doing and that's
what weight is as well to a certain
extent is putting on
Gabriel Iglesias did this podcast and we
talked about how he loves Iron Man and I
was like look I'm not trying to be funny
but like isn't it funny that you're
isn't it funny that your favorite
superhero is is somebody who built a
suit around him and like didn't you kind
of build a suit around yourself right we
were talking about having done this I
wasn't othering him I was like I did the
same thing like you want to put on
padding it's almost like the world is
too much definitely right yeah it's
overwhelming are you feel like a
sensitive person like it's all coming in
yeah
yeah oh my God and even now feeling like
I've done the work to feel free of the
perhaps and the the more negative parts
of that level of Sensitivity I feel
especially as you know like having kids
now it's like I'm I could go in a second
like what do you mean go I could cry I
could like I'm so emotional all the time
like I keep it in check cause I'm not
crazy yeah but like it's right here at
all times and I'll be amazed the the
Small Things I'll cry right now talking
about I mean this is a beautiful thing
but I was watching this show
um emergency NYC on uh Netflix you
haven't heard of it it's reality it was
it's basically just follows Lennox Hill
hospital and all the different facets of
it I'm giving it away but what can you
do there's this guy I don't want an
emergency NYC spoiler skip it yeah I'm
gonna call this two minutes go watch
something boring like Game of Thrones
like something fake yeah so dragons in
this IC yeah I like real
splice together fast-paced reality yeah
enjoy your red wedding I'll be over here
with lupus so
thank you another lupus so re-runner is
just lupus going around it's a Lupus
Awareness it's a real thing
um
poor Lupus if it was called anything
else
it doesn't it's one of the funnier
disease names
it does it needs a better public Loop it
can't be a fruit lupus is that what
we're doing it's rough does Toucan Sam
have fruit lupus is that the rep I have
loved ones who are not gonna love this
bit
do they have lupus
where does Luke does loopy come from is
that from lupus he was real loopy it
could be I don't know Lauren Lapkus does
she have Lupus yeah it could be keep
going oh so you you get emotional oh
there was like in this level I mean but
maybe it would level anyone there's a
guy who had been on had been in kidney
failure for like a decade and been in
dialysis and needed a a Kidney donor
badly could not get it on the list so
finally it and he's literally got like
six months left and he was in the NYPD
and he was like I couldn't actually like
even be a cop anymore because he was so
uh sort of compromised physically they
tell him he you got it we found a match
you got one and the person has made this
caveat that they don't want to be known
they don't want to give their name they
want it to be totally Anonymous but
they're going to give you the kidney
their match he goes okay a week before
he's about to get the kidney he's
signing some paperwork and some
paperwork got messed up and he goes
why is my partner for the from the NYPD
why is his name on this paper oh no
but five
why why is Sully's name on that wait a
minute pen shaking why is his paperwork
for Sully then a tight Club says he get
can we do it as an acting exercise yeah
this is him and he goes you do it then
I'll do yeah yeah of course great why
why is that hey a nurse why is this
paperwork saying my partner Sully
oh
I need a donut
you gotta do it okay you don't need a
funny line I just want the face I just
want to think and it's just for the fun
yes
okay uh I'll Lead You In with here's
your paperwork thank you here's your
paperwork officer for sure for sure I'm
already loving it with the for sure
you've seen the Mets last night oh yeah
I'm A working class person just like you
I love the mess
this is how they talk right I'm a
hard-working nurse and you're a cop of
course I watched the Mets I don't like
those Yankees oh God get out of here
uh Larry David on Seinfeld but you don't
see him the owner yeah
brother
look over here all right
that's good
why is lonzo's name here
I was trying to think of Denzel
Washington's character's name in
Training Day it's Lonzo it's Alonso you
in the office but he was a dirty cop he
was dirty he was no good but in a way
that he kind of understood yeah
streets it's crazy
guys the straight I mean this is I've
had moments like that driving because
you realize living in L.A yeah
old one kid
can you imagine the first day in their
squad car we don't have to do the scene
but the door closes
and they're just like we are going to do
this okay okay you're here you're Lonzo
so okay so I gave you the kidney this is
the first time we've seen each other I
get it
[Music]
nice sound huh yeah yeah
okay like this makes you uh
appreciate the things that yeah we're
right in front of you you know yeah good
[__] good [__]
this is um
reporting for Duty
I think I uh I left something in my luck
yeah
he can't handle it neither could I that
would have been an easy scene to play
because I couldn't handle it it's so uh
I was level I've been leveled for weeks
from that scene
feels good this is great do you like New
York New York did you feel that when
when you had a kiddo like just something
unlock in you in that way yeah for sure
and everything I know it's a cliche but
everything became so much less about
myself which was so important for
someone I mean the [__] pillows say
my name you know what I mean and so
there was a necessary softening and like
all the cliches but the cliche that I'm
avoiding I don't know why is I'm like
you see that she's good like this
morning she's been sleeping in our bed
and it's been awesome I woke up before
she did and did some stuff and then I
came back while she was waking up and I
was like I get to see her waking up and
she's just like she just goes like this
she's like total abandoned let's see
and just like instantly enjoy and love
and start rolling around and kissing mom
and kissing me and I'm just like I don't
have any needs yeah like she's good yeah
I'm her Lawns you know what I mean yeah
it's that yeah it's like having
something that you would give yourself
to
and you do give yourself to when my wife
and I are tired we're like babies are
really like those monsters in Harry
Potter that like suck your
like your face starts getting sucked
into their Vortex yes so all the like
people that don't have children
they're absolutely right they're like it
doesn't look fun I heard Seth Rogan be
like it doesn't look very fun and I'm
like you're right yes it's just so and
I'm not even trying to Counterpoint it
just saying there's so many beautiful
things that will never make sense to
your mind your mind will always go that
will deplete us that will kill us that
will age us that will hurt us that will
Tire us and exhaust us that will break
us yes and then your heart is like
Lonzo needs a kitten I know Lonzo is the
one that gives the kidding this doesn't
make sense I need two two kidneys yeah
you do it anyway it's amazing how I I've
my son is four and this was such a
lesson for me I don't know how you are
with the people apologizing to you like
you can make it colder in here sorry
Josh sure
starting to get sweaty with all the
Lonzo act out yeah I know it gets me all
worked up I am but I I don't know you
are with apologies but like if if
someone does me wrong and then they they
eventually do apologize to me or
something happens like sometimes I'll be
punishing even with my forgiveness right
and I'll be like various dude you're
gonna pay for that but yeah yes I
forgive because I know I'm supposed to
you know but
love this I didn't mean to interrupt
just couldn't wait yes
there's a I won't get all into it but
I'm reading something called A Course in
Miracles and they call that forgiveness
to destroy it's when you do something
that seems gracious but you're actually
just doing it as another way to attack
people and be superior so yeah to
forgive by acknowledging your error yes
is is sort of going like you know I
really should you really hurt me that
day yeah and it really did break my
heart and there were a lot of lonely
nights thinking about what you did and
you really like
salting it up right milking it yeah and
it's just another trip to feel special
and feel innocent and scapegoated
exactly and you just kind of get your
hit that's right you get a little I'm
good they're bad fix off of it Mercy
it's written on a Post-It over there
forgiveness is overrated Mercy is where
it's at Mercy doesn't even acknowledge
the the grievance that it just goes away
you open the airlock on the space
shuttle it's gone yeah you granted it's
gone yeah someone gets Mercy for a
horrible crime yeah yeah exactly there's
no yeah
get rid of it and and you didn't even do
it I like this airlock analogy because
it's like nature did it I just let it be
released I'm not looking at it and going
like okay I can cross that out right
let's see
I guess I could cross this it's just
gone because you need it too and it's
what we like you were saying the the way
your daughter wakes up and just
everything is fine and great and my yeah
my son when the other day
I was rushing to get to work and I
usually take him to school in the
morning and it was just one of those
days where and he was like I don't feel
good my stomach hurts and I just was
like I took your temperature you're fine
like trust me you're fine and I was like
come on we'll go to Starbucks we'll get
you the warm you like the warm croissant
we get you the warm croissant like it's
all going to be great you need a warm
croissant how many warm croissants is uh
gonna take to get me out of this yeah
warm croissant or Pepto-Bismol pick your
choice lean into the Hemsworth or we can
do it my way right you want some Vapor
Rub yeah
and I'm warm croissanting them up I'm
paying with the Starbucks app it's
gorgeous and I'm like
love the detail you don't even take my
wallet out no I'm on the app it's
perfect yes I'm redeeming gold stars
yeah and you know they're giving me
shots I don't even want I'm taking them
and I'm like listen if you don't feel
good tell you're going to school I'm
like but if you don't feel good tell the
teacher and me or mom will come and pick
you up but I I gotta go like I'm running
to work I'm sorry so I drop him off
within and there have been times where
he's forgotten all about had the best
day ever this was one of those times
where 10 minutes later the Call Comes in
yeah he's in tears he's holding his
tummy he doesn't feel good I think he
just had to get to the bathroom
regardless this morning Leela was like I
don't feel good I was like you probably
have to poop and she was like yeah
welcome to the planet yeah most of it is
pooping and sleeping yeah most of our
problems so much exercise pooping
sleeping and getting your heart rate up
Welcome To Earth yeah
and uh and uh and so and I felt awful
and thankfully my mother-in-law was able
to pick him up because my wife and I
were both working and and when I got
home that day
I took him to my office because I don't
know about your parents my mom is and
she's the best but she's never done this
yeah I'm like I took him to my office I
said
buddy I just want to apologize to you
I'm dead I can't even look at you I had
to break eye contact I I've said on
stage if my dad ever said you know I'm
really sorry I die yeah it'd also be a
part of me that wouldn't like it I'd be
like don't don't do this now don't take
it over we finish line yeah
it's like
my dad had found me or like come to see
me like no no perfect record baby take
it all the way you don't want it oh take
keep it clean yeah keep it clean I know
yeah like I wonder at his last moments
if he was like I did it right yeah we
that'll be me with Game of Thrones I've
never watched a Game of Thrones either I
didn't watch it
and you're a great show if it's any
consolation you're a great job
yeah no there is there is a certain keep
going though yes keep going so I I said
I was sorry and I was like you know I'm
gonna do a better job of listening I'm
sorry I was in a rush but when you don't
feel good I'm gonna really make sure
that I listen and he just looked at me
and said okay
like and I was like what a beautiful
lesson in forgiveness like to your point
the airlock it was done he airlocked it
yeah and he didn't do it I think Mercy
is more in line with our Natural State
meaning we develop these Egos and I'm
not even papooing the ego give me some
time I'll get there yeah I'm actually
saying the ego has obviously its purpose
it learns to distrust it learns to
protect it learns to hoard and store
predict unpleasant Futures replay
unpleasant past to like guard and not be
I won't be fooled again
and that is like a bodyguard that is
that is the nicest thing I can say about
the ego it is concerned it's not always
right in its methods but it's concerned
for this physical body and it's what it
perceives its well-being to be if your
ego was in a movie it'd be played by Joe
Pesci
laugh
sometimes
every once in a while it comes out as a
Billy Joel song for some reason a line
comes out and flutters
and possibly you know the song and we we
merge into a two-part Nami
um I love that so so much yeah it is Joe
Pesci yeah what the [__] did you just
it's that yeah and let's not just put
that down because sometimes we need that
but it's that structure it's overactive
like overeating overeating can be is
very similar we're supposed to eat fat
sugar calories we're supposed to get it
when we can so finish the milkshake so
that gets um enlarged and then we
overeat also your ego that's just trying
to protect you psychologically gets
enlarged and instead of what I'm going
to argue and this I'm four minutes
hypothesis on the Fly I think Mercy is
more our Natural State we start getting
hurt over and over and over and the ego
goes I've put together a a proposal yes
and I think you need to stop
forgiving I think you need to stop
trusting people because it's not safe
out there you know what I mean but your
child who is growing up in love goes
like okay and could and could flesh it
out no problem that's beautiful yeah it
teaches it teaches me everything yes and
it's you know I think about it too like
you know I'm a sober guy and I'm I'm 36
I'm 15 years sober and
what I know of my grandfather and I
don't know him I didn't know him at all
but like from what my mom says and I
hate to be like an armchair uh do any
armchair Diagnostics on someone but I'm
not that chip okay good okay wait you're
not sometimes people think I'm deck
Shepherd I get it
very hands done very well
it's always on that chips motorcycle
Just Around Town aggressively well
almost too well that's a little it's
enough too well yeah leave some for the
rest of us spread it around yeah would
it kill you yeah maybe the next offer
that comes in forward it to a Dax type
yeah which is me totally an accident for
12 months Fair
how may I ask how old you are I'm 44 I
just turned 44. are you toying with the
trt maybe testosterone replacement
therapy oh my whole life is working
towards finally being able to
rationalize why I should be on the
needle
what is trt trt it's it it basically
how they are they doing it Rogan is yeah
obviously yeah
um I'm trying to think of who else
almost every guy I know in Hollywood is
to a trt to a certain extent yeah
they're just it's basically is this in
um Bros when he's injecting in his butt
is he injecting testosterone I didn't
see it but oh homophobic yeah massively
to know you were closed-minded wow I did
you have anything to do with that movie
only that I loved it
is
yeah his whole thing
this isn't the clap Joe this isn't the
club
okay I've only been testosterone I've
only just repaired my relationship with
Judd Apatow so I will say Bros looks
incredible and I can't wait to see it oh
yeah wow I talked about this on uh oh on
ours I don't know if we did well not
that you'd remember no we have to wrap
this up
wow
like Peter tilling yeah different refs
um okay we'll get to you and how you
spurned Apatow but trt is you just take
testosterone and you maintain your
muscles and stuff the the argument would
be that like when people take
testosterone replacement therapy human
growth hormone that your body that's the
same thing they're different okay but
that your body naturally in your 30s and
then in your 40s down regulates these
things because it goes we're fully grown
yeah we have enough something like human
growth hormone which can speed up all
your good sort of hormones right like
your growth hormones you build muscle
you get more lean it also it doesn't
discern so it can also speed up bad
cells in your body like cancer and these
other things so your body naturally goes
I'm in my 30s I'm naturally more
susceptible to disease to bad things let
me just down regulate this a little bit
so I'm not constantly exposed and I
don't need to be perhaps be able to lift
as much as I once did right right
um so everyone just told me to not do it
by the way well I'm trying to yeah yeah
but everyone because I love this all my
friends who do it in their 40s will go
yeah you know I got tested I'm like let
me guess you're low like yeah it's like
if you get audited they're gonna find
something right right if you're looking
into your testosterone nobody's like
you're off the charge Conan yeah you're
fine it's not gonna be that yeah can I
tell you though in so I hate every time
I say this or maybe I'm embarrassed
maybe I can't like your acting coach
said stand up straight I've started
lifting weights which really spikes your
testosterone helps and I'll say uh look
if it's not testosterone it's something
else it's the wind of the devil I don't
know what it is but something blew up my
ass and when I lift weights I have to be
very careful the rest of the day and
sometimes the day after
um watch how I'm driving watch how I'm
uh handling conflict and this is not
Placebo right nobody's going like well
yeah like lifting weights isn't such a
highlight of my day that I just carry
the memory of it I mean like it's in my
blood and I'm like much more like like I
had a business call the other day and
and somebody I was just telling Katie
about it they quoted two way too big of
a cut of something like they wanted 50
and I was just like ah yeah no no like
I'm not that person just going like
that's ridiculous like and I had I had
lifted weights that then I was like so
testosterone's a Fickle [__] like it's
not just doesn't just turn you into
Jason Statham could also very well
explain a lot of terrible Behavior you
have to be careful right but like heavy
they say of all the exercises heavy back
squats because your your biggest muscles
are in your legs will create
testosterone in a way that very few
things can unless you're on the needle
interesting is that so is that what
you're doing no so I'm not on that but
like what the needle people in there
like I don't know if you uh Bert
Kreischer and Segura on their pod
recently shot each other up really with
TRD like on camera oh my God so it seems
to be like kind of the thing and it's
tempting but you can never get off of it
but it certainly will never get off of
it because I mean once you get off of it
you deflate yes and also because
basically you're telling you're giving
such a flood of it more than your body
would ever create that your body is a
smart little you know Factory and goes
yikes turn turn it off like we're done
too much is coming in yeah it's like a
disco being filled with bubbles right
[Music]
crazy people having too much fun
what is this Ibiza turn it off we can't
do that waist or lower with bubbles yes
okay so you're you're everything you're
telling me just makes it sound like it's
an awful idea your body's not ready for
dude I don't take melatonin because your
brain creates melatonin right and you
shouldn't supplement it it's like a I I
look I don't mean to go on and
onions but don't give it to your kids no
and people do they do yeah they were we
didn't know that I researched it and I
was like no it's something your brain
makes maybe if you go to Australia and
you need to reset your Rhythm you can
take the melatonin but not every night
just to fall asleep also it doesn't I
don't think it actually helps you fall
asleep it just does something different
it's different it doesn't just sedate
you it's doing something with your clock
I don't know how else to explain it just
Google melatonin Dr huberman but you uh
leave me alone and watch humor I call
him Drew
I do like CBD yeah yeah and this I was
gonna tell you about this this has hmb
this that's what Nirvana Water is and
that really helps with recovery and it
helps your body from losing muscle so
especially in your 40s my friend David
vanderveen who hooked us up with us he
was like with your recovery and weight
training they started giving it to
people who were sick and one of the
things that happens when you're sick a
doctor developed it for patients that
were losing body mass yeah they used to
get hmb in their system and that's what
this is also with D3 so yeah there you
go you can dude you can [__] have
that brother I'm gonna check yours yes
if I hadn't just peed I would be I know
you did a nearby coffee shop I'm a pea
guy
oh are you a big p I'll I'll ruin a road
trip I pee too much it's bad I wonder
because I've given a lot of thought to
this and then we have to get to food
because I just want to talk about that
with you please
how much is RP thing
I'm including myself in this oh boy here
we go I'm ready I fear that the Universe
isn't gonna take care of us yeah because
isn't best Josh and best Pete just kind
of like
because I can be this guy sometimes
like there'll be a bathroom
like let me put it this way
um if I'm taking something like MDMA one
of those like you know really lowers
your anxiety I know you're sober I'm
just saying like something that puts you
in that state could also just be being
in love or having a perfect moment yeah
oxytocin yes dopamine stuff is being
released however whatever means you're
just you're not so preoccupied with like
will I be able to pee you just have like
a more
I had this Revelation I was like
everything is anxiety everything is
anxiety it seems including even peeing
like stop the car
to me is bubbling up from a place of
like do you love me will you protect me
like I and you start forecasting a
future like how many miles to the next
thing can I stop this am I gonna explode
I so for me it's an anxiety issue as
much as it's a physical I gotta do that
but I I've I'm interested to hear this
what places give you a sense of security
if and when you do have to pee I'll
answer that Target I see a Target I know
I'm not gonna have to make eye contact
with nobody I ain't gonna have to look
at nobody I don't like having to say can
I have the key you know where I don't
can I also just say why did it take so
long for a corporate a corporation to
realize
just give them the bathroom yes give
them the bathroom let us have it give it
to them yeah unhoused people are gonna
go number two in there yeah yeah let
them let them let
because that guy's got a sock full of
nickels and he's gonna see that take
five bar on the way out that's right
he takes it too he takes a five all
right yeah yeah Rico likes not rages as
much as the next
you telling me because you don't have a
house you don't like a nutrageous
from Target is Joe Pesci apparently but
like no it's some other character I
don't know what it is yeah yeah give us
I don't even like Starbucks because the
bathroom is too part of the store right
you have to announce I think it's funny
that you're just standing in a room and
everyone knows there's tension in my
bladder yeah I don't like that Target
goes even the area where you'd have to
wait if someone's in there it's private
that area is basically a bathroom
yeah the waiting room is a bathroom oh
and then the bench and then they'll just
have like my favorite is taking a family
bathroom when I'm not with my family
can I just say Josh
that the family bathroom here's two pro
tips I got for you one you go to a hotel
you've been traveling a lot you want
some water um
but the water in the room that bottle of
water is seven dollars crazy here's a
[__] hot tip that no goddamn
[__] is gonna tell you go to the
gym yes sir
go to the gym yeah because guess what's
in the gym a cooler of free bottled what
same bottle yeah go get it you don't
even have to work out what are they
gonna stop you right I'm sorry are you
working out no I'm hacking the system
yeah cause I'm your king yes two
I love the family bathroom we were just
at the airport
I feel like this is look I'll never kill
a fox
I'll never start a fire
but I will spot a vacant family bathroom
when Val is about to walk what looks
like three furlongs to the ladies room
they go sweetheart
that's green that's green vacant yeah
and that bathroom's for you
oh you don't have a family
nobody's waiting for it yeah I don't see
a guy with seven kids going oh great a
lady went in there go do your business
that's right it's all poop and pee baby
the [__] porcelain mouth doesn't give
a [__] pour it in I I just think what's
gonna I'm gonna take my sweet time here
oh it's your little apartment it's a
little apartment there's even that bed
the plastic koala bed oh the koala take
a nap on it you can listen crackle in
curl up
curl up that's why it has a koala on
there it's literally there get cozy tap
into your inner marsupial I we did a
monologue on the pedome show about
bathrooms that we love and it's like I
want a turn lock I want like a lock a
deadbolt yes I don't want the push on
the thing crazy
I because you don't know is the door
fully like sometimes you really have to
push to a click and then you can close
it yeah I wanna ideally I want prison
style like the the bar oh I yes and then
clicks up yeah great I want one of those
posts that you can get from Amazon that
goes up into you yes and then it goes
into your like into the door jamb like
on a sliding door yes I want a sliding
door bar but the reason I'm gonna favor
the deadbolt is because that tells the
people on the outside occupied it goes
red oh God help you if you knock on that
red door if you knock on that red door
that red door no you know what guess
who's gonna try and take a second [__]
a spite [__] yeah because [__] yeah I'm
gonna scroll Tick Tock um I don't even
have a ticket I'm gonna log in I'm gonna
sign up you know what you got something
against the Chinese government I love
the Chinese
Chinese
brought to you by the Chinese government
that'd be a nice sponsor a sitcom you
know good spots what's that it's a nice
sponsorship oh yeah I mean it's not this
water china.gov you don't say this water
say Nirvana watersciences.com
there you go I know I know what it is
going to drink it you don't have to
don't you do it don't you I'm gonna put
down your microphone it'll be you look
at you okay let's talk a little bit
about food
they're very I know a [__] on it it's
impossible to open but if they bought
put a pen in the side and it starts
going out like [__] little boy blue
it's so good little Jack Warner who do I
mean the guy that puts his finger in the
hole
it's not this is a producer little Jack
blue little boy Bean
somebody's screaming at their radio
because they're listening to the radio
while they also listen to this podcast
this episode is brought to you by
betterhelp as you guys know I'm a big
believer in talk therapy I I first found
it when I was in a huge period of
uncertainty in my life I was in a new
city and in a bad relationship a
romantic relationship that I just didn't
know how to navigate through I didn't
know how to get out of it I didn't know
how to make it better I didn't know I
didn't know anything I didn't know how
to set up boundaries I didn't know how
to practice self-love and I certainly
didn't know what codependence was I
didn't even know what codependence was
until I talked to a licensed therapist a
trained professional talking to a
therapist is greater than the sum of its
parts it makes such a difference in the
core of who we are and those
conversations and that guidance can
change your life for the better it
certainly did for me because sometimes
the path forward isn't always clear
whether you're dealing with career
decisions romantic decisions anything
else therapy helps you stay connected to
what you really want while you navigate
life so you can move forward confidence
and excitement and trusting yourself to
make decisions that align with your
values you know it's like anything the
more you practice it the easier it gets
and in my experience having a trained
professional guiding you along the way
makes it that much easier so if you're
thinking of starting therapy give better
help a try it's entirely online designed
to be convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule you just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapists
anytime for no additional charge so let
therapy be your map with better help
visit betterhealth.com weirdo today to
get 10 off your first month that's
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash weirdo support your
your psyche support your mind support
yourself and support this show also
unrelated did you know we're eating and
drinking roughly a credit card's worth
of plastic a week a week yeah that's
right the products that we're using
every day are ultimately contaminating
our water supply generating hundreds of
microplastics that we end up ingesting
well luckily our friends at Blue land
set out to do something about it to
eliminate the need for single-use
plastic in the products we reach for the
most like hand soap did you know that an
estimated 5 billion plus 5 billion
plastic hand soap and cleaning bottles
are thrown away each year and if that's
not bad enough most cleaning formulas
are 90 water which is heavy to ship
leading to excessive carbon emissions
not to mention nasty ingredients in them
like chlorine and ammonia but blue land
is Reinventing cleaning Essentials to be
better for you and for the planet by
offering endlessly refillable cleaning
products with a beautiful cohesive
design that looks great on your counter
just fill the bottles with water drop in
the tablets and wait for them to
dissolve that means they don't have to
ship the water anymore that means we
don't have to waste the plastic anymore
that means hand soap toilet bowl cleaner
and laundry tablets all with clean
ingredients you can feel good about no
more bulky Cleaning Supplies on your
grocery run and refills start at just
two dollars and 25 cents I recommend
they're clean Essentials kit which has
everything you need to get started and
comes in beautiful light scents such as
Iris Agave fresh lemon and Eucalyptus
mint blue land also has an offer just
for weirdos get 15 off your first
purchase of any product and get cleaning
cleaning excuse me cleaning products
that I love the look of in fact if that
was the main thing for me it might be
the look of these bottles I like that
every room has this like through line
and Sleek design that looks cool but I
love that it's also good for you and
good for the planet so to get 15 off
your first order go to blueland.com
ymiw like you made it weird you won't
want to miss this blueland.com ymiw
that's blueland.com
ymiw all right let's get back to Josh
Peck
um okay food just because I'd love
actually let me this is even better I
heard you say on another podcast hmm
which was great it was you and some like
very restrained British man if you want
to hear like Josh not being around oh
diarrhea so not riffing or having fun uh
no I'm not that that's unfair you were
having fun it was a different it was a
different style I loved it though I was
like this guy was just like Josh your
mother raised you and then he just let
you talk I was like this is like a
master class in Josh Peck this is just a
hang that we recorded
um but you said you can't act your way
into new ways of
no you can't think your ways in a new
way of acting you have to activate into
new way of thinking right say that
properly I didn't say it right
um You can't think your way in the right
action you have to act your way in the
right thinking get the [__] in the canoe
God damn it we're going on a safari yes
we are that's incredible that's only
everything that means you know there's
like these the there are these slogans
you get in recovery and the annoying
thing is is that they're so trite and
they're all true
trite and true Triton true like stinking
thinking stinking thinking one day at a
time hey analysis is paralysis uh is it
otter is it God oh that's a good one
that's nice I like that one it's kind of
it's a little magical but I enjoy it
compare and despair compare and despair
as [__] dope yeah if you're not
grateful you're greedy it's not really a
saying you can't feel grateful and
Afraid at the same time as well yeah
that's a version of that I love that
yeah Jesus I've I've never gone to AA
but I think I'm gonna start going just
just because I never wanted to co-opt
someone else's trip you know I mean I'm
definitely addicted to alcohol and I
haven't had a drink in seven years oh
wow but now I have a good friend we're
getting closer and he's in the program
and I'm just like in awe of him because
of stuff like this so tell me what that
means well I I it connects to another
phrase uh and obviously the beautiful
thing about 12 step is that it's a god
of your own understanding right so
there's no but but there's a lot of God
talk in it so I understandably and there
are certainly people who are agnostic or
atheists who have gotten sober with the
help of 12-step like you can do it sorry
I'm just thinking about the clouds
parting and like a deity coming out with
a flaming sword it's like the Rapture
and he goes kneel before a god of your
own understanding it's like incredibly
like spacious yes it doesn't it doesn't
demand Fierce loyalty it's like however
you think of me it's like one guy just
kneel into like the ocean there's always
one guy that's like my higher Powers the
ocean oh [__] yoga Hot Yoga did
something I hope it wasn't Bikram jeez
seem that doc watch that duck after
emergency NYC on Netflix right it'll get
your heart back to cynical right okay so
higher power of your own understanding
but there's also this phrase in
intercept of something like uh I've
never needed God to or I've never had to
I've I've never had to think my way out
of something God's got me into but I've
needed God to get me out of something I
thought my way into
let's [__] slam dunk it's just good
[__] it's good [__] and it's wet
sometimes it's stuff like that that you
feel like you have to live another 10
years to like fully get that you're like
I know that's true yes but then when it
really like proves like a like dough
when it proves yeah now I really get it
I mean I can only speak to my own
experience because it's always tenuous
sort of talking about the 12-step stuff
but I I'll say for me like when I went
in and they said um you're self-centered
and I said there's no way
I said because that's reserved for
people who like themselves yes and they
were like uh-uh they're like if you
spend your whole day thinking about how
great or how shitty you are you're
self-centered preach and I was like
gotcha and they were like you need
self-esteem I was like well I don't know
that's impossible right I have low
self-esteem like oh the way you get
self-esteem is by doing a steamable ax I
was like huh they're like so go clean
the coffee pot like I'm that kind of
dumb that's like um
FDR's wife right wasn't she in the
program was Eleanor Roosevelt in the
program it was a famous it's a famous
one and I just embarrassed myself but no
it was Eleanor Roosevelt well it was
it's pretty close somebody out there and
they were like go clean the bathroom and
that was like the first thing that she
had to do and she learned like if you
use the bathroom you should clean the
bathroom yeah like like that's a good
lesson like there are no new ancient
truths right so these are tenants like
to me the miracle of 12 separate like
whatever you know the yeah the miracle
of 12 step is the packaging right that
it took these ancient truths and any
great religion any great sort of
spiritual tenant has taken gratitude
except in surrender and it just
repackaged it in a way that a drunk like
me could understand it and it made the
entry fee instead of piety and walking
in proud Brokenness that's right you
walk in Humble you actually woke walking
shattered and embarrassed and that's
sorry to be so Christian but that's what
the cross says it goes you fall upward
you you crucif you die and that's how
you figure out who you are it's not
it's not that that thing is learned from
in the Winner's Circle right that's
right yeah it's always it's it's the
last house on the Block like you never
learned anything on a good day my best
thinking got me a front row seat in a
right and that's like and and that's
sort of like that that humility where
it's like finally being willing to try
it someone else's way which has been
such a that's the whole thing you're
admitting you're wrong and admitting
that even your Badness is an ego trip
what were you gonna say you said you
said this on my pod I'll never forget it
and because I have to go and you're like
thank you I have to go Disney boy I
think I said I don't care how many
followers you got let's get me out of
here by the way earlier you said 3.1 and
it's actually
16.1 people is it really yeah I'm
crushing it your Wikipedia needs an
update and anyone can do that tell me
about it
yeah
look at me different point one YouTube
oh yeah yeah 3.59
it's been a slower belt YouTube's harder
it's more based on Talent anyway
YouTube's a [__] it's harder to grow
that's where we are yeah I get It's
Tricky it's yeah it's tough but we're
also okay acceptance yes I'm having a
great time you know what I mean here we
have those ones you're like what am I
complaining about yes I wish the YouTube
numbers were bigger shut up [__] shut
the [__] up what okay what is that for
you right because like I mean I loved
crashing obviously I'm a massive fan of
yours and you know I I would imagine not
to project but like there are those
boxes that we I would imagine guys like
us have like love a show love to have a
show that I create and I guess if I
could pick any network at bhbo yes right
so like box checked yeah yeah so then
what very generous question I'll answer
it quickly because I want to get back to
your thing sure I want to write and star
in a movie that that would be the next
thing cool yeah because you can really
control what you want to say and I know
that sounds maybe pretentious but also
what you want to do like instead of
waiting for someone to like write a
movie where you can shine you go I know
how I'm funny I'm funny silly dancing
I'll write a silly dancing scene I'm
funny yes I feel like people respond
when I'm like that so you can just do it
and it also just feels like the next
medium to be honest I'm really I've been
a little blocked on that I've been doing
it for a while yeah and that's kind of
how I know I'm on the right thing
because I'm like scared well he goes
like I don't think you're gonna do it so
you're like oh good like like Jordan oh
Michael Jordan yeah oh good now I have
an opponent so it makes it a little bit
more compelling isn't it amazing how
fear can give you such a fog like I
remember oh my God I did this you don't
even know dude I did this show for one
season on Fox where I played John
stamos's son grandparented grandfathered
close grandparented would just be about
the grandchildren yeah these guys are
great prune candy I love it I mean I
wish I could teleport back to 13 year
old Josh and say buddy yeah one day
we're going to be able to pass for John
stamos's spawn yeah so stop eating so
much trans fat and get happy because
it's gonna work out yeah yeah stop
eating frosting yeah frosting's a topic
gravy it's not a beverage
sure it's a delicious wheat
so I'm auditioning for the show
the show is basically it's conceit is
that this wonderfully Debonair dashing
sort of 50-something clooney-esque type
guy finds out that not only does he have
a son that he had never met but that kid
has a kid so he's a grandfather in an
instant yeah and I'm sitting with my
friends
exactly
huh it's literally yeah
and he has a kid hold on
has anyone ever done that that's
brilliant a double yeah yeah put it in
your movie they did one on uh done they
did one on 30 Rock which she's talking
and then someone said something and she
goes and she goes I wasn't even drinking
anything they've done every version of
it keep going
um and I remember I'm so I've got the
sides and it's that scene where I'm like
uh you dated my mother's eyes yeah
you dated my mother and and and uh I'm
your son
and I remember I'm with my my buddy
who's great actor and I go yeah man I
just don't know if I'm right
I don't know I don't know my way into
this thing
he goes
hey dumb [__]
like dumb [__]
it's you yeah it's you yeah and I'm like
hilarious can you like that's how blind
we can be to our own realities I texted
Ryan holiday I saw him yesterday no [__]
yeah that's right uh no we were in at
the airport together in New York no
randomly right into each other crazy
yeah well I was so I was felt so
privileged to be able to text him but I
was like look I've had this movie idea
for years like you getting the show this
ties in I mean I was like I don't know
why why can't I write it like I was like
look I know I even said I know you
usually make like 30 grand an hour to
answer questions like this but give old
homsy a free one or mark this is Spam
always give them an out or Market a spam
but I'm just like I have the movie
outlined I have the idea I have
producers attached he wants me to start
make it they have the deal set up why
can't I write it
and he goes it sounds like the
resistance and I go what's that he goes
you need to read a book called The the
war of art yeah you've read it yeah see
I see everybody press field yeah Stephen
pressfield who I'll reach out and have
them on the pod but just watching
Stephen pressfield on other people's
podcasts I immediately was like oh
that's what it is and I can't you know
perfectly summarize it chat GPT can it
really can but um basically it's this
idea that you're your ego we're back at
ego doesn't want you to merge into
Transcendent creativity and and perfect
Flow State where you're constantly
channeling and and discovering on the
unlimited potential of the collective
unconscious it wants you to be you it
wants it would rather you be broken and
afraid but definitely the ego then be
like ethereal and light and vanish into
nothingness so there's this like
existential fear to like having your
dreams kind of come true or pursue that
thing or write that book so it tells you
who are you because it's worried that
you'll figure out who you are in the
process which is not your ego and broken
and Afraid is familiar it would rather
you avoid the unknown miserable then
risk it for potentially better but also
maybe worse yes broken is is that yes I
sort of cut you off you were saying to
get yourself esteem up you have to do
esteemed acts that is that what you
meant by the ACT your way into better
ways of thinking yeah it was just this
idea that like I I cannot think my way
out of situations like I literally have
to
it's like a hard reset and what I've
learned is that it's only in service of
others and it's only by like like if I'm
overrun and it's a beautiful thing of
having a kid and if I'm overrun with and
it's it's just those old familiar
feelings right I'm either in fear of
losing what I have or not getting what I
want like if it all boils down to that
right I can't I couldn't possibly live
with less right it's like that's the
same too right like the key to getting
more is wanting less and I I don't know
that one that's a good one that's a good
one and also wanting what you have also
is such a key to everything just go like
and we try to do that with our daughter
it's like she wants more and more and
more and we go baby I know wanting is
like a monster there's always another
want it's like the trick is to want what
you have and like as I'm saying it to
her I'm like I have to do this yeah you
know what I mean and it's this great all
these things like allowing your kid to
uh you know take away your attention
from self or making that phone call
immediately like taking action to do
something for someone else is like the
thing I would walk in my 20s just so and
sober but just leveled by an audition
leveled by something that my projection
my expectation of how I thought it
should go it did not live up to that
expectation it never did yeah and thus a
flood of self-centered Fierce spirals
come around and I'm in twisters and Bill
Paxton's not to be found yes and
Helena's not in this movie and I'm just
like alone with my self-created
tornadoes of so it's all self-centered
fear and um and it is an ego trip too
yes all of that it's all about me it's
all about me keep going yeah and and
just taking that action I remember early
on in spreading my first six months I
just was terrified to talk to anyone
about anything
and guys would say get really good like
you want to get our respect like get
really good at cleaning out the coffee
pot wow like go stack the chairs either
with it every kung fu movie it's you're
right there's no new ancient wisdom go
sweep the steps you know what I mean Get
Low yes
and acts of service that's what my my
sober friend was saying because I I I
don't like this about myself but I
struggle with my dog my dog's is like
this endless need machine that's what I
project on to him sure he follows me and
I literally go what dumb [__] think
this is love what [__] desperate
idiot thinks their dog loves them you're
walking around eating a turkey leg and
he's following you and you're like oh
sprinkles loves me he wants your scraps
he's looking for carry-on yes he's a
vulture right he that's his Instinct he
can't help it I also I can speak from my
truer higher more spacious free self
Brody and I love each other I can get
into that space for sure but if I'm
pinched and tight and I wake up and he's
barking or he's begging or he just wants
his food and he just I I just happen to
always look in the yard when he's
[__] with his thin legs shaking and
[__] and I'm just like I have to get
into those acts of service I can't it's
just exactly what you're saying I can't
think my new way I can't I have to act I
have to go and pick up his poop yeah
with love you have to feed him with love
have to pet him and that's what I've
started to do it's like I have these
like feelings of completely undeserved
anger or frustration towards my dog and
if you get down you start petting them
you get him a treat oh my God cleaning
the coffee pot do you wanna like people
I think we romanticize these things of
like to have these moments is is
you know these spectacular like Cloud
parting moments you wanna have a real
moment of Grace in Los Angeles where you
live yeah take someone to the airport oh
my God you want to talk about of the
highest order yeah you want to talk
about being a a Los Angeles monk yes be
willing to sit or pick someone up from
the airport first of all they got worse
worse that person will be like are you
serious yeah because we're all so
conditioned of like this is you better
be asking a family member yeah yeah yeah
or like someone who owes you or someone
you helped him hide a body or whatever
right it's a debt or you wanna you help
someone move you're gonna feel good for
months this is this is something it's in
A Course in Miracles but it's in other
spiritual things as well giving is
receiving yeah that's the whole thing
and if you go alone you're not going no
one goes to heaven alone right it's only
what you give it's only where we go
together it's in my giving heaven and I
just mean that energy that space that
frequency here and now in me giving you
my respect and my attention and you know
some kindness that's how I it's
literally I don't mean then you'll want
to be it doesn't mean it means in the
giving it's already been given to me
it's that's just how it goes and if you
don't believe me not who who's I mean
maybe you don't believe me but you can
literally close your eyes it's a
Buddhist practice loving-kindness it's
also in the course you close your eyes
and you just think of different people
maybe people you don't like and you give
them stuff you you give them respect you
give them Joy you give them peace but
like as you say it you'll feel your body
and you'll be shocked that your body can
Kaleidoscope internally in in as many
different ways as it can you'll feel I
wish you uh peace and you'll feel peace
I wish you Joy you'll feel Joy Bliss
fulfillment yeah all of these things and
you get them as soon as it leaves your
brain and it doesn't matter if they
receive it it's happening Here and Now
it's happening it's crazy it's one of
the biggest secrets of life there's one
kid right now looking up from his 48
Laws of Power and going like I'm turning
this off I don't like this part of the
pot what's Brendan Shaw talking about
put on a branded shop podcast
um I we didn't really get to food and
that's okay I do love it I know but I'm
I'm I've been this size for the last
almost 20 years and
it's not on the Forefront I think I got
I don't want to say got it licked you
can't I can't I can't let knock that but
I um yeah because
food was but a symptom of a greater
problem that centered in my mind right
when I lost the weight and I discovered
drugs and alcohol I said right this is
way better right right of course so
that's really like mine now the cause
yeah and the cause was love self-love
lack of Love lack of who knows right I
mean what we know is is that
here we go with the Saints again from
Penn State to the state pen from Park
Avenue to the park bench right like
addiction doesn't you know discriminate
right so but we also know that there are
families where like the kids in theory
had the exact same upbringing pretty
much the same environmental input and
one person could suffer from addiction
and the other doesn't yeah so sometimes
there isn't like massive cause usually
there is uh but yeah I was I suffered
from this thing I know my grandfather
had it he was nice enough to give it to
my mother and my mom gave it to me but
luckily she found help earlier than he
ever could and and then I found it
earlier than her and now my son who's
four God willing will only be a
respectable amount of [__] up right
right but it took generation enough yeah
just enough to be interesting but food's
the first Frontier right it's a thing
that we first have access to that's
that's what I just want to get out there
as often as I can is like just some
awareness that there's addiction at play
there's a dictionary this is Richard
Rohr he wrote a beautiful book called
breathing underwater which is about the
12 Steps he goes everyone's addicted to
their own way of thinking which is just
brilliant so nobody it's not the addicts
are over there and we're over here
everybody's addicted yes and then food
is just like it just never occurred to
me
growing up in the 80s that that was a
thing that like eating six bowls of
cereal I thought that was like I was a
champion or something yeah you didn't
realize that you were trying to
almost
um is the word Tamp down your feelings
like you want to weigh them down you
want to push them down and and getting
honest and
curious about what is it that's so
unbearable and it's hard it's like Luke
going into the cave you know in Star
Wars and he sees the Darth Vader helmet
with his face in it but we have to do
those Journeys instead of eating the
whole bag of Cheetos and then it you
know correct me if I'm wrong but then
it's also like and if you do eat a whole
bag of Cheetos don't have that addict
thinking where it's like well now I'm on
a bender you know what I mean sometimes
mistakes or whatever whatever you want
to say happen yeah I need a dozen donuts
which I do not that's it yeah yeah I
have my moments for sure it happens I
don't get black and white because
addicts can be very black and white and
you go like well now I'm a I'm an eater
again and it's like it doesn't have to
be that way you can stop and breathe and
and call somebody yeah and remember
your support yeah it's always you know
um I don't think I leave God God doesn't
leave me like I can always sort of go
back in any moment and you know when I'm
in and when I'm really and I don't again
I don't want to make it sound so
uh what would religious I guess the word
would be like I I you know there are
times where I'm on that freeway and like
I'm in God cruise control right I'm just
doing for others and I'm not overly
worried about anything and I'm just like
I'm on it and then I see an exit for
money and I go God
trust me yeah I gotta go do this yeah
it's gonna give me a little bit more
security yeah I'll get right back on the
freeway soon and the Universe goes yeah
and like and that's usually where it
leaves me but I think you're right I
think as kids were born without control
we're a victim to our own circumstance
and you know food is a celebration it's
also something you do when when things
are low it's something you do when
you're bored yeah and I just didn't eat
chocolate like my fellows I over did
things yeah yeah yeah and
and but to your point all that addictive
stuff it kept me safe as this kid who at
my default was too sensitive for this
world yes I always say I was I felt like
I was born without the same manual that
everyone else got at Birth that like I
didn't have the same suit of armor man
you will Dad I'm just kidding yeah
dude you know I hate to say it I didn't
get the man
that's an even better one Giannis Pappas
made that joke too no oh yeah he's like
I was like you know I always just felt
like I didn't know how to Traverse the
world and like all these things like
yeah that comes from a dad he's like you
don't need a dad he's like a dad does
that oh my God
right
true though the pain recognizes pain you
know what I mean yeah and you're looking
for that control in the laughs and
eating like what a big Epiphany for me
was like I like guaranteed experiences
and I like the Arc of a of an overeating
experience I like the hope that maybe
this time it will be awesome yes and I
like the crash that it didn't work and I
even like the recovery Chelsea Peretti
helped me understand that it was very
normal to binge on alcohol and then have
an incredibly healthy day the next day
and she was like that's that's kind of
classic attic stuff and I was like what
I'm killing it isn't it great that I get
up and go for a run and she's like it's
like a cycle I don't know if she said
this but she helped me realize that I
was in a cycle yeah of that sort of
thing I I noticed it in my shout out my
wife's siblings who after a hard
charging night at the bar or whatever
because they're like in their 20s and
early 30s so it's still like very
acceptable and they'll have like you
know every now and then a hard charging
I I can almost guarantee I'm like
I'll say to my son I'll be like your
aunt's gonna come over with donuts this
morning I know it at like 7 A.M almost
to be like I won't I won't be held down
by my night of debauchery like I'm a
good person that's right and those
donuts are good yeah I'm like yeah yeah
where are you with God now we only have
a little time here sure but I gotta get
going
would that have been a pretty good mic
drop moment if I like really cut it off
yeah I mean it wouldn't be forgettable
fair you know it would be Unforgettable
something and people would be like did
you see that I've done enough work on
myself I'm good with being forgettable
let's chat
forgettable is where it's at actually
touch it it's hot [__] I'm not Barack
Obama no you're not Beethoven No we're
gonna be forgotten and so are you and so
is Beethoven
yeah but it's gonna take way longer but
let's take an asteroid there's like one
every generation that'll be remembered
yeah and even that won't be Kevin Hart
is the man yeah maybe won't be
remembered in 100 years maybe I no
disrespect to Kevin I would make all of
us all the comedians
who is talking about George Burns you
know what I mean
it's the greatest yeah and now you say
let's see Georgian see he was a Duo it
doesn't matter that's my point yeah
shaky green just in the way here's one
of the eye like it's Eckhart Tolle the
way you feel right now is how you feel
about your life that's it this feeling
how do you feel right now can I tell you
something else yeah I've started
exercising I think it's just spring I I
bet you could track my cardio with the
seasons like the winter I'm just like I
don't know man you know what I mean when
the spring comes and I'm like I love it
why do I ever not do this but I've been
exercising uh we have a Peloton at
peloton.com weird I'm just kidding
um but I've been just doing 20 minutes
on it every day and loving it and so
much so I think I'm addicted now I I I
might be speaking too soon but here's
the moment and I just I want you to
speak to what gives you this feeling so
it's really a question but
I noticed that when I wake up in the
morning one of the first things my brain
will say to me is what are we worried
about and it wants an answer it doesn't
it doesn't it goes we have to worry
about something
and it's almost like I have a hat hook
in my mind and there's just ever since
I've been a kid there's always been a
hat on that hook yeah and nobody ever
said like do you need a hat on that
surely they have but I mean deep in my
unconscious so if I'm really quiet I can
hear it go what we need to be worried
about something and since I've been
exercising 20 minutes first thing in the
morning but really sweating like
to to exhaustion basically yeah
um now I get a voice that goes or maybe
we don't that's right and it's so weird
it goes instead of something have you
tried nothing meaning not an answer
not a fix I'm not even giving you a
solution or a mantra I'm just not adding
anything to the already empty space
that's doing just fine does that make
sense oh yeah
what does it make you think of a number
of things that did you hear Seinfeld on
Tim ferriss's podcast what's the deal
oh poor Jerry the mind the mind the mind
is like your boss but you can't fire you
ask for a raise it says no
dopamine's right at the right level
uh what did he say he basically he just
said he's like your mind
is an ox that needs a plow attached he's
like I've never seen an ox in the wild
but I imagine they just kill themselves
like
they're just looking for a cliff it's
too much yeah too much energy I'm an ox
yeah give me something to plow he's like
you gotta put another quote of his on
Howard Stern he said find the torture
you're comfortable with I saw that one
that was good too but it's the same
thing and so you you pelotoni every
morning is like uh-uh not today mind
you're not [__] in charge it buddy
I'm a little tired today because I went
to bed around 12 30 but I woke up at six
and I can you I feel like you're here
for this you're okay with us yeah you're
just a loving person so you'll allow the
slight brag but I I say it
most of the time I don't feel this way
this morning I woke up at six and I was
like what what are my options my
daughter's sleeping next to me about
sleeping next to her like okay maybe I
could go back to sleep for 45 minutes
right is that really
is that really anything or get up
Peloton before your body even realizes
that it's tired and hungry yes just do
it right away buddy I did that
cold Plunge yes hot tub yes pool
I go back upstairs to take a shower
they're still sleeping I feel like
[__] Robin Hood yeah
and the fox one yeah animated Robin Hood
you are showcases choco willink
I heard you call your dad what is the
word you used
about your dad a raconteur raconteur it
felt like I felt like I should have dice
in my Puck yeah you're Showbiz Navy SEAL
and they were still sleeping and I'll
say out of the other side of my mouth is
there anything more annoying I love Tim
Ferriss yeah but if you're not in that
way and you listen to Tim Ferriss talk
about a morning like that you're like
[__] off like it's so disheartening
right so I'm just saying this in
celebration finally I had a Tim Ferriss
morning yeah you beat up your brain I
beat it up I put a plow on the ox yeah
the pink cave pain cave the pain cave
it's what like ultra marathon runners
talk about like I'm in the pink cave and
I'm aware of it and I know it and I'm
not going to be dictated by this pain
yes my body will give out eventually and
hopefully I stop maybe a minute before
that but like pain is familiar I know
this feeling it doesn't scare me that's
what's been helping me with Peloton is
is I know it's a video yeah there's
something kind of sad about that I guess
maybe I should be with friends
but it takes too much effort to go like
let's all go bike riding crazy when I
whenever I wake up yeah crazy if I'm in
the mood nah dangerous so I have a video
and it's a little black mirror but the
person in the video is you know months
ago years ago saying don't give up and
it works yeah they go like I know it
hurts and you're like
is this sweater tears yeah I cry a lot
on the on the Peloton I do I I can't get
a full tier going because I'm too Irish
but like I'll get like an emotional
response and I'm like and I love it and
I'm starting does that relate does that
unlock
feelings oh yeah
I don't who is selling
Fitness to us the wrong people gym
teachers [__] Michelle Obama nobody's
telling us the truth which is like
emotional Freedom psychological Wellness
pain cave that's [__] that's great
marketing I had to put a podcast to find
this [__] I mean it should be on the
food pyramid I think uh you know I'm
sure you know Alan de botan no but I'll
have one is it a soup with cheese on it
the best what is it he's like a modern
day philosopher and and does a lot of
podcasting but he just talks about how
we're all taught hygiene from you know
my son's been brushing his teeth since
he had teeth right so like he's been
taking a bath since you know a week
after he was born like all these things
yeah we don't teach mental hygiene we
assume that you're just born with it and
it should just be there wow and like if
we really made a point at an early age
it's what I give my son now of just like
you've been on that iPad too long
there's no way you're going to be in a
good mood
I mean without listing them but all of
the [__] things going on in the
country how many of them are like we're
not meeting our psychological needs yeah
communal needs personal needs interior
reality needs like there's isolation
there's depression there's anxiety
there's dread there's despondency
there's Despair and these things have
cures like not cures they have treatment
treatment it's a way better because they
are illnesses but we were worried about
tartar I look I'm all about Russia I'm
not all about brushing your teeth I hate
brushing with you but like I'm just glad
you're getting this out there because
nobody's really explained to me like
if we all only ate uh fried chicken and
only watched uh TV alone in a dark room
and never saw Sun sunlight yeah Drew
huberman told me again sunlight first
thing in the morning DH
balance never got sunlight never got
fresh air never got community never did
acts of service never did esteemable
things never believed in something
outside of myself never participated in
something outside of myself never gave
of myself never became vulnerable to ask
if anybody needed a ride to the airport
never took care of my body so I can
maybe have that feeling that maybe I
could be of service whatever it might be
none of that was taught and then and
we're watching what happened I always
think about the Black Mirror where
everybody's in a a cell basically and
every wall of the cell is a screen and
guess what it's not just titties and
[__] it's not right I know that's a
funny way to say it but it's not just
feeling pleasure whatever pleasure might
be yeah Marc Maron says cake and coming
cake and coming yeah it's better it's
not and that's what I was just talking
to somebody about chat gbt one of the
things it was Kenneth pattengale from
the Milk Carton Kids was at uh my Largo
last night and we were talking about
I'm I'm a an AI Optimist I think it's
going to be incredible obviously it's a
little scary but so is every huge change
but I'm also like I think this is going
to be huge and big and strange and all
the things yeah the risk is what's going
to happen to the Kenneth pattingales
that were so bored that they were just
playing a record over and over and
trying to copy a lick on a guitar over
and over and over like when you can just
ask a thing to cheat for you and write
it for you or think it for you or
process it for you the cake and coming
starts to look like the point of life
but I was thinking about on the drive in
I I remain optimistic human beings will
never underestimate human being's
potential to get bored meaning they'll
get so bored that they'll want a new
pain cave right computers are doing all
this well I can do this like will we
discover ways we build roller coasters
for fun you know what I mean like
somebody was like maybe a magical town
where a mouse is the mayor like we do
crazy [__] because there's something
there's a spark in humans that go I
don't care what tools are available you
know what I mean yes like the Jim
Gaffigan bit I'll find a way to
challenge myself as the other side of
that Jim Gaffigan had a bit about the
technology of umbrellas like the first
person that had an umbrella it's like oh
you're too fancy to get wet are you like
it's every technology is like how's this
going to ruin everything human beings
will always be unsatisfied and that will
lead to
more expansion more Innovation it's the
best just to show you that money really
doesn't make you happy is how much Elon
tweets right
will always be dissatisfied you're just
a real a Duke and you know that you're a
real red Fireball back when it was
random oh the red one
your sparkly little boy that's what I'm
saying your mom was right she was all
those [__] finish the joke that's
great
woman wants to get breast enlargement Dr
goldstein's
scene go under the knife you could just
do this and if you get bored go Mary had
a little lamb so one day a month later
her bust has grown she's walking through
the mall going Mary had a little lamb
guy sees her and goes hey you're a
patient at Dr Goldstein she goes how do
you know he says Hickory Dickory Dock
Hickory Dickory Dock it even rhymes with
[__] like it's great you're welcome
thanks Mom she's alive but I don't know
why I looked up she's up there she
watches from the rafters all some people
watch clippings and stuff she's up there
she's my backup
um thank you Josh thank you man such a
failure YouTube moderator I'm just
kidding give me your team I yes as a
thank you give me your tooth yeah this
is my honor you know I thank you
um and thank you for doing it and I
really am embarrassed about our first
meeting I'm glad we got a round two me
too and I have a I have a new podcast I
hope you'll come on for only 45 minutes
and then I'll come on do a hard out and
as a joke the good guys won't leave for
three hours good it'll be ready I don't
know if I can set the record who's the
record nowhere and uh what I should have
done better is say I'm not crazy this
will take an hour ish which is you need
to know about that story is I don't
remember it that speaks to the state I
was at just drained and dead and I won't
forget this me either there it is thanks
would you say keep it crispy I point to
that like you need to read it but it's
how we end keep it crispy will you say
it like Casey Jones from Ninja Turtles
because I watched that with my daughter
really oh my God I think it's one of the
coolest things you've done whoa keep it
crispy
and you and you get with Raph yeah and
you fight yeah that show's good it gets
too dark for four-year-olds season three
yeah I could see that season three it
takes a weird turn it was a hit show and
then yeah it was like crushing it and
they were like new cast we're like What
the
what the we're we're doing yeah I
noticed that yeah because it wasn't at
Sean Aston and then it wasn't Shawn
asked it was him and um uh they're all
perfect Jason Biggs was Leonardo they're
all and then it was and then he was and
then it was Seth Green which was even
some might say better could maybe well
you don't have to no but Seth's done the
show and Jason hasn't so we'll say it
was it was better I love Seth but it was
great that's the best yeah it was great
it was great that's a great show yeah
like if if I didn't have kids I would
watch Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles 20
what year do you have to type in because
there's so many different ones 20 12
2012 yeah 2012. it's great we have the
toys we have to go deep on eBay to find
them wow no Casey Jones though
look me up I'm just kidding I'm working
on it she she uh she's moved on
can you introduce her to Blimpy
oh my God we're a blippi free household
and I'm proud to say that oh we're not
oh God I got him to make a video for my
son I'm doing well you have to do I got
the real people's gonna do it he did it
no he made a video for my son oh he did
oh yeah that's nice it's great that tree
is great and it was like 75 seconds I'm
like you get a video from us is that
Cameo no no
yeah
I'm not gonna stupid camera [__] on
Cameo oh my have you ever in blippi
would make 250
000 a month on Cameo what's your
rationalizer because I've had two Cameo
well like because you know you get those
dark moments and you start to
rationalize it you're on the highway
with God yeah
he grabs the wheel not [__] Cameo
no I have no problem with camera no me
either I'm not anti-cameo I just
I don't want to work for Cameo right and
then that's what I've been told is like
it's fun and then your inbox fills up
God willing let's say that's nice but
then you have this other thing you have
to do and I'm very rarely in a mood to
just do and I wouldn't want to do it
half-assed I wouldn't want to do it like
dead-eyed and sort of sad and you know
what I mean Julie it's your Bot mitzvah
oh sorry I'm supposed to be Batman uh
sorry this is what you're getting like I
have the Benson and hedges with the ash
I don't know maybe it's Pride too maybe
you're like it's it's just it is a
little corny there's a corn factor that
you have to get over that you're like
I'll say hi to you for money like it
right is that it yeah again no
disrespect to the no because who did it
did dice do it did he I think there was
someone who was doing it and was doing
like nine minute Cameo so I was like
that's legendary Andrew Dice Cameo
that's not a cameo that's a lead
that wasn't a walk-on you're now the
second lead
that wasn't a cameo that's our website
not a cameo not a camera it's for the
people you're not using actors I'm not
yeah I get not yet this writer strike
goes too long we'll all be on Cameo
catch me isn't that why I'm going like
no disrespect no disrespect because I'm
always like in the back of my mind yeah
there's a little parachute I'm wearing
called Cameo and see that Batman mask
it's not cameo.com Pete homes it's slash
Batman and it's just me being like happy
birthday Julian oh yeah it's a wide
that's a wide net
bad man would kill it on Cameo you
kidding me I want a cameo from Batman
yes Jesus Crow so see you all in there
when the strike keeps going I love you
guys
catches on caviar IO
[Music]